namaste i'm from india and india is one
of the oldest civilizations in the world
it has contributed to the world concepts
such as yoga ayurveda spicy chicken
tikka
and vedic math vedic math is one of the
world's
easiest and the simplest way to do math
we're gonna combine together and do some
number crunching today so what we're
gonna first do
is multiply by 11. we're gonna do it
together
so if you blink you're gonna miss it so
just
watch it okay
so we're gonna do 32 times 11 okay so we
split three and split two and we add
three and two and paste it in top and we
get the answer as 352.
that's it
let's try the other sum 45 times 11
that's you
exactly that's 495
and 75
times 11
so it gives you seven thousand one two
five one gets carried over and it
becomes 825.
that's how simple it is
okay this is the principle behind it
where uh
a
is the coefficient let's move on
okay now what we're gonna do is the base
method okay this is used to multiply
numbers very close to the powers of 10
like 10 100 000 and so on so we have a
sum here say 99 times 97
okay now tell me is 99 more 100 or less
less by how much
so we write
minus
0 1
and 97 is less than 100 by how much so
we write minus zero three so what we're
gonna do
is we're gonna cross subtract and get
the first part of the answer like this
so we're gonna do cross subtraction
minus zero one would give us
a 6 and we multiply 0 3 times 0 1
vertically and we get our answer as 0 3.
let's take another sum try and do it
yourselves
got 98
which is is it more than 100 less than
but how much
and 97 is
three so we got 98 we go crosswise we
got 98 minus 3 or we could do 97 minus 2
they all give you the same answer so
that would be giving us 95
and the second part would be
0 6 so that's our answer
okay
let's take a bigger number let's try
this one
here the base is
so we got
-004
and and 7 would be
minus 0 0 3 we go crosswise
like this
and we get 996 minus 003 would give us
993 and 0 0 four times zero zero three
would give us
zero one two and that's our answer
thank you
14 times 12
okay here the base is 10
okay so it's 14 more than 10 or less
than 10
more so we got plus 4
and 12 we got
plus 2 again we apply the same rule so
we do 12 plus 4 which gives us
like this
and we multiply 2 and 4 that gives us 8.
so now
all of us here we're gonna do mental
squaring
okay everybody's gonna participate here
and we're gonna do squares of numbers
more than 100 mentally right now so we
got 101 okay now visualize
on the board what's going to be on the
right hand side
plus
0 1 so we got that
okay now we add crosswise right yes no
so we got 1 0 1 plus 0 1 that would give
us
1 0 2
and
see here
like this
and 0 1 is getting squared right so that
would give us
0 1 and that's your answer
try the next one
let's try 1 0 2 squared
let's try everybody
so 100
so 1 0 2 would be 1 0 4 0 4
okay now the next one try it everybody
together i'll give you five seconds
okay let's let's say together let's say
together
okay
one zero six zero nine and that's the
answer
one zero four squared how much would
that be
calculate five seconds
come on girls at the back
okay so the answer would be
one zero eight one six
okay let's do the next one
one zero five squared
oh no no no no we're gonna try over
we're gonna try over okay
okay i give you five seconds just think
about it
okay now we gotta go okay
one
one zero two
five okay that's gonna do the next one
one zero six squared try it come on
everybody simple and easy
okay let's do it one more time one
one two
three six
now one zero seven think hold on don't
say anything a lot just think mentally
107 squared
okay now let's say it a lot
one one four four nine
and
one row eight square
fantastic give yourself a round of
applause come on
and this is the principle behind this
where a and b are the excesses or the
deficiency from the base
now i'm going to teach you in vedic math
there's 16 sutras or word formulaes okay
they're very visual and one of them is
called vertically and crosswise through
which you can multiply any number by any
number in a single line so i'm gonna do
two digit
by two digit
uh multiplication let's do this so we
got 31
times 12
okay so we're going to apply the
vertically and crosswise sutra so we're
gonna do like this
vertically then we're gonna go crosswise
and then we're gonna do
vertical again
so 2 times 1 gives us
2 times 3 gives us
and 1 times 1 gives us
6 plus 1
1 times 3 gives us
and that's it and that's our answer
no more tedious calculations
no more going to the rough work is
simple in one line
i'm going to show you a sum again this
time with carryovers the same formula
all of us here can do this okay
same formula so let's go start it 4
times 2 gives us
okay now we go crosswise like this so
we're going to multiply 4 times 1
and 3 times 2
4 plus 6 gives us
so we put down 0 carry 1 and 3 times 1
gives us
plus 1
exactly that's our answer 408
okay
thank you for being such a participative
audience and we had a great time number
crunching now i want to end with a
question
whether
you would like maths to be dull or
boring
or fun and interesting the choice is
yours
you